si querías saltarte las partes de
cálculo de esto del movimiento armónico
ahorita es un muy buen momento para
regresar porque ahorita ya no vamos a
platicar casi nada acerca de cálculo
pero vamos a hacer un pequeño repaso
para eso aquí puse una gráfica es otra
vez un resorte y simplemente es este
mismo dibujo pero ahora lo puse de
manera vertical ojo esto no quiere decir
que ahora haya ninguna fuerza de
gravedad actuando ni nada extraño sale
simplemente lo puso lo puse de modo
vertical y al lado de esta gráfica para
que podamos compararlos y tus agarrarle
un poquito más de intuición al asunto
bueno como decíamos aquí en cero en cero
el resorte está en su posición de reposo
y ahí no pasa nada pero si ponemos una
masa en un extremo del resorte y jalamos
hasta este punto que era el punto a pues
la fuerza restauradora iba a empezar a
generar un movimiento que acababa
haciendo el movimiento oscilatorio si
aquí arriba teníamos una gran energía
potencial que poco a poco se convertía
en velocidad hasta llegar aquí donde la
masa tenía mucha velocidad y bueno
una gran energía cinética pero luego iba
a empezar a desacelerar hasta llegar a
este punto menos en ese momento la
velocidad era cero pero ahora se iba a
ir para arriba y seguíamos haciendo eso
vale ahora eso se puede comparar con la
gráfica de aquí a la izquierda que es
básicamente lo mismo ahora empezamos
aquí en este punto que es el de acá aquí
no tenemos nada de velocidad la
pendiente es 0 pero aceleramos y
aceleramos si aceleramos y aceleramos
hasta llegar aquí al punto de pendiente
máxima o sea de velocidad máxima después
de lo cual empezamos a desacelerar y
desacelerar hasta llegar a este punto
donde otra vez la velocidad de cero la
masa está acá y bueno ahora vamos para
el otro lado verdad otra vez aceleramos
y aceleramos y aceleramos mucho hasta el
cero y luego desacelera vamos y nos
aceleramos hasta llegar al punto
muy bien entonces eso fue eso bueno aquí
está la interpretación pero además lo
que vimos en vídeos pasados usando un
poquito de ecuaciones diferenciales que
era la parte de cálculo lo que vimos es
que la posición del resorte al tiempo te
estaba dada por esta ecuación de acá x
de t es igual a a coseno de raíz de cada
entre m por t muy bien esta ecuación y
bueno no es que yo apoye memorizar cosas
pero esta ecuación es muy útil memorizar
la porque nos permite encontrar bueno no
sólo la posición claramente nos permite
encontrar la posición verdad porque pues
es la adecuación de posición pero no
sólo eso también nos permite encontrar
otras cosas del resorte como su
frecuencia o como su periodo o si
sabemos un poquito de cálculo su
velocidad va entonces para ver esta
ecuación en acción vamos a encontrar
digamos pues el período del sistema de
este sistema de acá ahora ojo estoy aquí
es un movimiento armónico simple sí
entonces hasta ahorita no te había dicho
pero es simple y lo que quiere decir es
que se pueden modelar con una función
trigonométricas como esta de acá
modela cosas que oscilan sin considerar
fricción bueno pasemos al periodo y a
ese periodo ya le habíamos llamado te lo
que lo que habíamos dicho es que es el
tiempo que tarda vamos en regresar en
regresar a la posición original la masa
iba a menos a y luego regresaba a y todo
ese tiempo que tardaba era un periodo va
entonces cómo le podemos hacer para
determinar el periodo pues lo que
queremos es que la masa vuelva a
alcanzar el punto a y aquí ya tenemos
una expresión que nos dice dónde está la
masa cuál es su posición entonces lo que
queremos ver es donde x dt o sea para
que valore sus dt x de t es igual a pero
para eso conviene estudiar tantito que
le pasa a kossen o no porque x dt es
igual a a
justo cuando coseno de esta expresión de
aquí adentro es igual o sea coseno de
esta expresión es igual a 1 entonces
pregunta donde sucede donde sucede que
coseno de un cierto ángulo teta es igual
a 1
pues en cero es una posibilidad verdad
teta de jose no de cero es es entonces
cuando te es igual a cero cero quedó
bien feo cuando teta es igual a cero
tenemos que cocinó dt t es igual a 1
pero también al darle una vuelta del
círculo unitario verdad en 2002 si si te
estoy confundiendo un poco con cosas
trigonométricas y 0 y 2 pi
te recomiendo que le eches un ojo a los
vídeos de funciones trigonométricas pero
bueno en 0 en 2000 también en 4 p de
hecho en todos los múltiplos de 2 pi
tenemos que coseno de ese ángulo coseno
de un múltiplo de 2 pi es igual a 1 eso
está muy padre eso nos va a ayudar para
ver donde x de tve vuelve a ser igual a
entonces que necesitamos necesitamos que
coseno de lo de aquí adentro sea igual a
1 y por lo tanto déjame tomar el color
verde necesitamos que esta expresión sea
xd xd t es igual a cuando esta expresión
es igual a cero
2 y 4
y así sucesivamente pero lo que nosotros
queremos es darlo en términos de t si
queremos la menor te la menor te que
haga que regresemos a entonces justo esa
te corresponde cuando cuando tenemos que
lo de aquí adentro es igual a 2 pib que
entonces que necesitamos que necesitamos
para encontrarte a pues este justo va a
ser en el que esta expresión sea dos pi
y vamos a ver cuánto es vamos a despejar
t entonces estamos pidiendo que raíz de
cada entre m década entre m porte sea
igual a 2 p2p y por lo tanto
multiplicando entre ambos lados por el
inverso de raíz de cada entre m
tenemos que el período que es igual es
igual a 2 p2p por raíz de m
entre k muy bien esto está bonito déjame
ponerlo en un cuadro porque esta es una
fórmula interesante que nos da el
periodo nos del período de un resorte
entonces
si alguien no se vas caminando por la
calle y alguien te pregunta lo siguiente
o bien si estás en un examen y te piden
el periodo de un de un resorte y tú
conoces la masa y la constante entonces
le puedes decir el periodo es 2 por
píriz de m / k muy bien eso está muy
padre pasemos a otra cosa ahora pasemos
a la frecuencia la frecuencia de una
cosa es cuántos ciclos da por segundo
pero el periodo es cuántos segundos se
tarda en cada ciclo
entonces la frecuencia la frecuencia no
es nada más que el recibió el recíproco
del periodo es 1 / t
es 1 / te va entonces la frecuencia es
el recíproco del periodo y entonces nos
quedaría igual a 1 / 2 pi
y el recíproco de este de acá raíz de
acá entre m bueno entonces aquí está la
fórmula de la frecuencia esta es la
fórmula del periodo y la verdad yo
siempre siempre he tenido problemas para
memorizar me cuál es cuál y luego me
confundo si va a un 2 piso o qué cosa
entonces pues prefiero memorizar me nada
más la de la posición y a partir de ahí
deducir estas dos sale deducir estas dos
de acá entonces otra vez bueno para eso
tengo que acordarme muy bien cómo
funciona lo de las funciones
trigonométricas así que te recomiendo
que la re pases otra vez como te conté
tengo vídeos de eso así que puedes ir a
checar los en cualquier momento va ahora
otra cosa interesante ya tenemos el
periodo y ya tenemos la frecuencia pero
hay algo padre ni el periodo ni la
frecuencia dependen de a del punto al
cual estiramos la masa eso está muy
sorprendente no sea lo que nos está
diciendo es que si ponemos la masa acá o
si la ponemos acá de cualquier forma
vamos a tratar lo mismo en regresar o
vamos a dar los mismos ciclos por
segundo entonces
creo que es más claro si hago el dibujo
aquí en la gráfica voy a ponerlo con
este color rosa entonces digamos si en
vez de estirarlo lo estiro como por aquí
ahora el objeto empieza en esta posición
y otra vez con velocidad cero misma idea
va pero como tiene el mismo periodo como
tiene el mismo período
entonces volvemos otra vez en el mismo
tiempo que esto está padre si
simplemente ahora tenemos una menor
amplitud tenemos una menor amplitud pero
el periodo sigue siendo el mismo y ya
nada más para finalizar déjame dar un
ejemplo numérico porque a lo mejor bueno
porque es bueno contarte esta cosa que
te voy a decir porque algunas veces en
los problemas nos piden no estirar la
masa sino contraer la sino a éste
apachurrar el resorte entonces pues
podría ser que te digan que que se
apachurra tres unidades entonces en este
caso tendríamos que a es igual a menos
tres y no sea de más pensemos que nos
dicen que la constante del resorte si es
que la masa es 2 va entonces si nos dan
esta información nos dicen que estamos
saturando el resorte 3 y a partir de
aquí podemos determinar la ecuación de
la posición del resorte otra vez nada
más nos vamos acá arriba y tenemos que x
de t
es igual a que es menos 3 por coseno por
ccoo seno de la raíz de acá entre m 10
entre 12 -cinco entonces nos quedaría
raíz de 5 por t a partir de aquí ya
podemos sacar periodo y velocidad si
sabemos derivar y otras cosas pero
observa lo más importante de este tema
es aprenderse esta fórmula de acá o
saber reducirla pero era la todo esto de
la ecuación diferencial así que si es
muy útil memorizar tela a partir de ahí
puedes deducir el periodo y esas cosas y
si de verdad te da mucha mucha lata
trabajar con funciones trigonométricas y
poder reducir el periodo pues también
puedes aprender de esta fórmula va y
está esta fórmula que está aquí está de
acá del periodo y la fórmula de la
frecuencia pero bueno si no tienes
muchas prisas en un examen y puedes
reducirlas de hecho te recomiendo eso
más porque vas a aprender pues mucho más
del tema y vas a acostumbrarte a
trabajar con ecuaciones en fin espero
que te haya gustado este vídeo de estos
vídeos de de movimiento armónico y nos
hasta la próxima